[Music]
it was an amazing Oscars amazing Osgoode
you tell us what it was like being there
and tell us everything well most of what
I thought he was a lot of fun and the
opening number was great
it's set up you know afternoon everybody
was enough festive mood and then at the
end I actually heard the stage manager
was stopping in front of me
and so I split before it happened I said
what are they gonna do now are we good
and then I saw him get on stage and then
I said oh my god they're gonna say it so
I actually saw it before everyone else
it was kind of freaky but exciting and
I'm just glad that at least this year
two movies got to get up on stage and be
celebrate right there's a positive and
what was your favorite moment with Jimmy
Kim um he went to candy coming down with
the turkey
I was so grateful there was because
every time I've been there I've been
starving and this time I got to stop
myself your girl after my own heart
I like that and I'm ready to go get more
food
[Music]